all right senator Kim
yeah
three two
ready ready to go hello everyone welcome
to simulation my name is Alan Saki and
I'm your host and today we're sitting
down with Steve Bryson what's up hey
boom here we are planets planets planets
are up that is very true but more stars
that no more planets than stars I would
hope so I would hope so yes
so so simulation pairs together global
leaders or thought provoking questions
and a patreon update for you is that
boom come and support us patreon.com for
/ simulation series get exclusive
content get early access to know who our
guests are get priority and asking them
questions and get access to our live
events early so join us as a member
please and help support us as we go and
inspire the world with these
thought-provoking conversations shout
out to Ron Vargas on the TriCaster
crushing it he's doing an incredible job
and we're gonna dive right into it Steve
Bryson works with NASA he is in the
Kepler science office and the Kepler
mission is probably arguably
the coolest and most impactful space
project why don't you give us a little
tiny bit about what the hell Kepler is
so Kepler is a space telescope that was
launched in 2009 and its purpose was to
find planets around other stars and more
than that to find enough planets around
other stars that we can actually talk
about populations of planets at
statistics and answer questions like how
many planets are there per star in the
galaxy and it has been successful beyond
our wildest dreams at launch as and as
we hinted at the beginning there we've
now shown that it's it's certainly true
that every star on the sky when you look
up at night every star on the sky
on average has at least one planet and
it's very likely that there's more than
one planet for every star on average so
by on average I mean if you pick one
star maybe there's no planets there but
if you pick another star there might be
3 or 4 or 9 or 15 so we've expected that
there were planets around other stars
since
the Greek times that this is not a new
idea that there planets around other
stars and those of us who grew up in the
60s had Star Trek and there were planets
around other stars and Star Trek and of
course there would be planets around the
Stars but that's not the same thing as
knowing not the same things actually
having found them and Kepler to the
Kepler space telescope was not the first
that didn't find the first planets
around other stars but it did find a
very very large number of them enough
for us to start to make statements about
what what the average is and and we've
now believed that there are more stars
than planets as we said of course I'd
certainly hope that's the case because
our star the Sun is just one star and
it's got depending on what you call a
planet it's got eight or nine or
fourteen planets yeah and it's great to
think about it historically with people
laying laying out for the last thousands
of years looking up at the stars and
thinking what is going on up there and
now we're insanely propelling these
massive telescopes up into orbit
then observing what is actually up there
and so maybe we talk about so the method
so we used to have a different method it
was the Doppler man and now we use just
transit photometry method maybe we
should well there are there are several
methods of finding planets around other
stars but I think we have to start with
the thing that may not be so obvious to
everybody and that is that finding
planets around other stars is really
really really really hard and I want to
stress here that finding the planet
means you're detecting its existence
you're not seeing it in any meaningful
sense until very reasonably you're only
you're only able to tell it's there
indirectly so the very first planets
that were found in 1995 or there was
actually one found in 89 but my good
friend Dave Latham who found it he was a
little shy about announcing it but you
know I'm pretty sure it's a planet
discovered in 89 but the first planet
that was really announced yes it's
definitely a planet around another star
was in 1995 and that was found by what
you call what you referred to as the
Doppler method well what we do is we
carefully watch the light from the star
break it in two colors and then it once
you were able to break the light in two
colors you're able to measure the motion
of the star and if you do that carefully
enough then you can actually detect the
star moving back and forth
and that's what would happen if a planet
a big planet was orbiting close to the
star would actually the gravity from the
planet would be pulling the star back
and forth and we were able to actually
detect that in 1995 but that only works
for large planets very close to their
stars at least at the time so there
weren't a lot of planets that were found
that way it was in the few tens by the
early 2000s so we knew he had a planet
here and a planet there and a planet
there they were all really big they were
all really close to their star closer so
they were all very hot
aka hot jupiter yeah that's right and
just so clean and quick just so when mmm
good because we have gravitational pull
the star has the most gravitational pull
tip that's right over the planets but
the planet still have a little bit of
gravitational pull on the star yeah and
so then you can tell that by breaking up
the light you can tell if the star is
being gravitationally pulled that's why
the planets and therefore you then say
hey there's at least one planet that's
pulling the star and then thank you for
for clarifying that it
because the star is so big and the
planet even though it's a big planet as
planets goes a lot smaller than the star
the motion of the star being pulled by
the planet is really tiny so these are
really hard measurements to make which
is why took until 1995 to do it for the
first time and why it can only be done
for a few stars these days were better
at it they found a few hundred planets
this way smaller planets but still still
generally hot planets close to their
star
but it's a very small effect very
difficult to find what Kepler does is a
whole nother technique oh and I should
stress that when in that first method
where you are seeing the motion of the
star you're only seeing the motion of
the star you're not seeing the planet at
all you're inferring the planet from the
motion of the star that's crazy and for
its complete inference asleep so
indirect inference that's right yeah
that's crazy but it's it's an inference
we're very confident yeah so we're sure
we do fine planets that way but it is
only we're only able to tell how massive
how much gravity the planet has has
which tells us how massive it is it
doesn't really tell us how big it is it
doesn't really tell us what the planets
made of we're not seeing the planet at
all in that method
but we are able to tell the orbit of the
planet because that you look at how the
star is wobbling you're able to tell
what the orbit of the planet is and how
massive it is using the Doppler method
the Kepler space telescope uses a
different method which had been used
successfully from ground observatories
previously for a small number of planets
but it was the vision of bill Borucki
who is one of the wonderful grand old
men here at NASA Ames whose vision to
put up a telescope with a very large
field of view so we look at a big chunk
of the sky it's about that big if I hold
my hand out a big chunk of the sky and
if you look at it long enough what
you'll see is if you get lucky what
you'll see is when the planet goes in
front of the star it'll block a little
bit of the light now when I say a little
bit I really do mean a little bit for
something like Jupiter it can block as
much as 1% of the light and that's not
very much so we see the star dim but
just a little bit but for something like
the size of the earth a planet the size
of the earth it's blocking one
ten-thousandth of the light and that's a
very tiny little dip and so bill Bergey
said to himself hey you know it is a
tiny dip but if we've got really good
measuring devices we call them
photometers because they measure they
measure light photo meters photometers
if we've got really good
measuring devices we can see those teeny
little dips and we can actually detect
earth-like planets around other stars
earth size sorry now there's like bad
language earth sized planets around
other stars but you couldn't do it from
the ground because from the ground the
atmosphere just shakes everything up
it's very noisy it makes the star light
twinkle and so you had to put a
telescope up in space and that was build
groupies vision and it took him a long
time to get NASA to agree that it was a
good idea but he did succeed we launched
in 2009 and as particularly 20 years of
putting things together as well well it
even there it took 20 years his bill
berceuse original idea was in 1983 so it
took 20 years to convince NASA that we
could have enough precision in our
measuring instruments to actually see
these very tiny dips Wow but NASA
supported NASA did support and just you
know it's small levels did support the
experiments to show it was true and then
once it was shown it was true the NASA
put the full weight behind it
and that's when I was lucky to get hired
into the mission but so using using the
the what we call the transit method when
the planet goes in front of the star we
call that a transit we're able to tell
how big the planet is because how big
the planet is
determines how much of the Starlight it
blogs just tells you how much the
Starlight dipped and we're able to tell
the orbit so because the light will dip
and then maybe a hundred days later the
light bulb
thank you yes we could tell the orbit
because it's a repeating dip and we only
counted as a detection if it repeats
three or more times more time and this
is the error thing which we'll get into
yeah that's right yes but but there's
one catch with the transit method that
makes it very difficult is you have to
be lined up so that the planet goes
between you and the star yes in the case
of the earth going around the Sun that
and that would only happen in 1 out of
200 cases so if the plants were just
aligned randomly you would need to look
at 200 stars on average in order to just
see one of these dips from an
earth-sized planet in an earth-like
orbit around the Sun and so you know you
have to know which looking a bunch of
stars only one in 200 of them is going
to have the transit events even assuming
all of them had a planet
and so what do you do well bill
brookey's vision was to say well I don't
know which stars look at because it's 1
in 200 we don't know which one so what
we'll do is we'll look at lots of them
and so it was that a hundred and eighty
thousand well we ended up at about
looking constantly for about a hundred
fifty thousand two awesome
so the Kepler telescope had a big field
of view we could watch a hundred fifty
thousand stars what we did was he sent
it up there pointed it and one direction
in space and this carefully selected
part of this guy and we just stared at
it for four years because you have to
watch for those dips which in the case
of the Earth orbit only happens once a
year so you had to stare at that once
but once by the sky for four years and
you had to move the telescope so that it
would it would stay yeah exactly we had
we had to make very sure that the
telescope stayed very still yeah and I
want to give a shout out to ball ball
aerospace who built the Kepler space
telescope because it turned out to be a
marvelous very accurate instrument Wow
which was able to station this day
staring exactly in this direction
until it couldn't we'll talk about that
so so this has been now you joy did you
join in pre-2009 insular Science office
and so then you were kind of on the end
of getting ready for all the data that
would be coming in preparing some
visionary work for what it would be
doing and all that kind of stuff yeah
yeah so just kind of summarize how it
all started
yeah yeah for me personally yeah so
actually I didn't know about the Kepler
mission at all I'd never heard of it and
I got an email saying from I've worked
at NASA already at the time and I got an
email saying hey we saw your resume and
you look like somebody we could use that
on our team but when I looked it up I
looked it up on the web what the Kepler
mission is this was in 2004 when he
looked up what the Kepler mission is my
jaw just hit the floor and oh my god and
so I just dumped whatever I was doing at
the time over the side and which was fun
but it's not this 15 years since that
email
crazy beam and the Kepler mission does
really weird things in a sense of time
I'll tell you that because these
missions are so long - every time that I
talk to people at NASA it's just it's
just you can you can it takes half of a
lifetime to put something in paper id8
on it get it an execution giving proves
right put it up there actually collect
the data and then be able to what so so
I joined in 2004 and that makes me a
newcomer there were people who had been
on the mission since the mid 90s trying
to prove that it was going to work Wow
and so and so what my job was before
launch
my job was primarily to first of all
simulate the data that we were going to
get and I wrote a lot of software to
show what we would get and that was
mostly for testing testing both just to
make sure we knew how to send all the
pixel data wherever it needed to go but
also we use very sophisticated computer
algorithms to pick out these very tiny
dips and so I was writing the simulator
that made simulated tiny dips that we
could use to test the algorithms and
make sure they work before launch and
you guys got a pretty high success rate
on algorithms oh we always get a higher
success rate on our simulation doing
well they are but then when you launch
and you get the real data it always
turns out to be a little different but
it was certainly certainly close to what
we simulated and then the other thing I
did I was responsible for was using the
simulated data see one problem we have
with Kepler
is that we're looking at a big piece of
the sky and oh I should have said that
we didn't just launch this thing into
space like the Hubble Space Telescope
that orbits the earth orbiting the Earth
would have created all these terrible
noisy signals the earth is a terrible
place to be looking for planets from
even near the earth is a bad place to be
looking for planets from so we sent the
Kepler spacecraft far away orbiting the
Sun actually behind the earth as it goes
around the Sun but far away from the
earth now it's millions of miles away
from the earth and so there's a problem
in that you can't send down all the
images it's just too far away you just
just don't have the bend and you can't
send astronauts to go on home and you
can't send astronauts to go and help it
which will be important later in the
story and so what we have to do is pick
out the pixels we want of the Stars we
decided to observe so we were looking at
this big piece of sky which actually has
six million stars in it but that we knew
about but we had selected 150,000 for
our observations because they were the
most similar to the Sun they were bright
bright to a relative thing actually too
bright was bad Tesla is very sensitive
if it's too bright you don't want it and
we carefully aimed Kepler to not have
any really bright stars but we got we
got very very we the bulk of our stars
were very dim much much much too faint
to see with your eyes and dimmer than
our Sun or about well they're dim
because of their distance yeah they were
like a thousand light years away or yeah
a thousand would be an average some of
the ones we were looking at go to about
3,000 light years so we're not looking
at nearby stars what we're trying to do
is look at lots of stars which means
you're looking at a lot of faraway stars
and so because we could only send down a
subset of the pixels we had to pick out
the pixels for the stars we wanted
and we had to be very we had to be very
efficient we had to pick out just the
pixels we wanted because that's how we
got 150,000 stars if we picked out a big
patch of pixels we would have had fewer
stars and so my job was to pick out the
pixels
to write the software that did that that
was fairly intimidating because yeah
that was that was one of the few people
in the science office who if I screwed
up would have caused the mission to fail
yeah it was sort of funny so I went to
the launch we all went to the launch in
2009 and you know like you know a little
nervous at launch not sure what's going
to happen because Rockets sometimes and
so the the rocket launched successfully
it looked wonderful it was beautiful and
it was after it was successfully placed
in its Sun orbit orbit around the Sun
about two hours after launch it was
confirmed that everything is working is
when I got really scared but it works so
very very happy yeah exactly
huge high-five again that's that's an
incredible moment for you and for the
team when it actually gets up before
yeah okay so let's talk about so 2009
until 2018 so where we are now what had
been so obviously had been observing
that patch of sky observing the dimming
you need to have at least three orbits
in order to confirm it as a exoplanet
around that star so this data that has
been collected
you know maybe talk about you know what
how it's been the almost ten years what
has the data looked like all this good
stuff well I wish it was almost ten
years so yeah so what what happened was
that it worked very very well for four
years
and then our ability to a component on
the spacecraft broke that destroyed our
ability to keep it aimed at that part of
the sky very carefully yeah so we ended
up with only four words so those are
called reaction wheels reaction wheels
just steer this basic aware of them
mm-hmm there were four and we and we
ended up having to break on us in 2013
two broke well one broken in 2012 and
then the second one broke in 2013 to be
exact and then you were still able to
from that point continue well that what
we were not able to do was continue
looking at the same part of this guy
okay we were not able to so that data
collection ended and so that's what we
called the Kepler prime mission that was
a couple of Crimean then that was about
four years of the 150,000 stop - did you
look somewhere else for the next well so
so we thought of course in 2013 when the
when we lost the ability to point
accurately you thought oh my god it's
over that's it but then we but then
people said well but you still have two
of these reaction wheels and what you
can help you help you even in you know
two ways that the problem is you have to
control your attitude and space in three
dimensions right and but with two
reaction wheels you can only do
hmm okay well the people who built the
spacecraft at Ball Aerospace they
thought long and hard about this problem
and after coming months they came up
with the this absolutely crazy sounding
scheme which is what they did was they
said hey you know what if we point in
the direction of the orbit or opposite
the direction of the orbit either way
works if we point the spacecraft in the
direction of the orbit we can actually
balance the solar light pressure so
light from the Sun exerts pressure Wow
we can actually balance a spacecraft we
balance a telescope using the solar
light pressure so long as we're pointed
in the direction of the orbit or
opposite direction of the orbit because
it's sort of one big TV and so they came
up with a scheme to use the light
pressure from the Sun to substitute for
one of the reaction wheels oh my god and
then we use the other two reaction
wheels to keep it pointed exactly what
we want
and then let and then and then there's
just a tiny bit of roll and then what we
do is we use the actual thrusters on the
spacecraft to control the roll yeah by
firing the thrusters add a little bit of
limited amount of thruster capacity so
every six to twelve hours only a couple
years yeah you started we started this
mode in late 2013
and it's still going no way yeah
absolutely all way it's been five years
been running five years in this mode
it's will only cast what we call the pay
to mission occasions different name
because it's a totally different concept
unfortunately it can't just pick one
started part of this guy and stare for
four years that because as you orbit the
Sun you know you kind of keep pointed in
the direction of the orbits but but the
ball guys were really clever they came
up with a way to keep us looking at one
spot for as much as 90 days at a time
then you turn my gosh so it's so
interesting cuz we go up with the
intention to look at one patch and all
of a sudden there's a solution
thank goodness humans the advanced we're
now looking 90 days at a time in a new
patch every times a new patch or are we
we've been we're a little opportunistic
what we do is we say we can look sort of
that direction and and the the
difference with the k2 mission is we no
longer think of it as just planet
finding we think of it as a general
astronomy observation mission and so
what we do is we say hey we can kind of
look in this direction and we ask the
astronomers in the world what would
what's in that direction that you'd like
to look at and we find we find a
particular direction to point that
catches as many of people to astronomers
desires as we can so we'll look at that
patch for well and then we'll ask the
same question over in that direction and
and so sometimes when we come back
around we'll look at the same patch okay
so one look at it sometimes will look
slightly different awesome
in five years five years and so then did
you guys decide to potentially look at
exoplanets or star systems that were
that were maybe only ten light years
away or 25 light years away or something
closer to us because it was maybe easier
to observe that for a short period of
time or were you oh yes definitely so
the thing about stars is stars come in
very different brightnesses so there's
big bright stars that are just really
hot and bright like fake like Vega is
one for example and then there are
really small stars that we call em
dwarfs really small stars where they're
very dim very compared to the Sun and
they're very cool and so for a planet to
orbit and we haven't talked about the
habitable zone yet yeah just the right
distance where the temperature is just
like the earth temperature for the
planet to that's a very close orbit
which is a very short period yes correct
and so you can actually get three or
more orbits is that in that 90 days or
something yeah yeah so identify planet
even though you're only looking for 90
days
circle around and so there's there's
more of an emphasis on those very dim
stars in the k2 mode cool but you know
one thing we haven't mentioned is it's
sort of a funny sort of a funny thing
in the original Kepler we were just
picking one part of the sky and looking
at for for years you know what a boring
telescope right I mean met might be good
for finding planets but you can't look
at this you can't look at that
can only look at things that are right
there so interesting what do you most
but but the amazing thing was that no
one had ever taken a telescope and
looked at stars not planets but just
stars for four years on an erect with
high precision yes and that has actually
been something of a revolution in just
stellar astrophysics is getting this
very long time high high accuracy
measurements of starlight has
significantly enhanced our understanding
of how stars work so it's been a it's
been a revolutionary observational -
sorry it's been a revolutionary way to
observe stars which has had some very
very significant impact on our
understanding of stars but it hasn't
really been a revolution in the
understanding of stars because they
already did what we proved was that the
theory sort of right I recently saw the
Goddard video the NASA Goddard video of
I think it was ultraviolet
telescope okay of stars and it is just
crazy Canyon solar flares oh yeah yeah
happening I that video blew my mind and
I'm just I love that video so okay so
this is crazy so k2 is an album that you
know five years strong going let's let's
touch on you know habitable zone seems
like it's a very you know a pretty
familiar concept for people the earth is
in a habitable zone it's not too hot
it's not like mercury or Venus too close
to the star it's not too cold like Mars
and a further out apology's robot I just
hit you
so so so that's this is the habitable
zone now the habitable zone changes
depending on the star because some stars
are brighter give you the habitable zone
can go further out sometimes or dimmer
it can be closer in and so now you we
have a lot good amount of data on on
different what different habitable
planets orbiting stars how bright those
stars our majority of the stars is it
close to life but 70% are these dim em
dwarf stars
oh well it's certainly true that the
majority of stars in the galaxy are
these small M dwarf stars that's right
and so if you were to just count all the
stars that are close to us most of the
close stars are these M dwarfs but
they're so dim that
before they get very far away there they
haven't been detected yet so thus in
terms of the stars we know about the
specific stars that we know about the
population of these M dwarf stars is
comparable to the other kinds of stars
but that's just because there's so many
of them out there that we don't know
about cuz they're so small and dim and
that that would be kind of like to say
maybe the star star our Sun was maybe a
hundred times less bright than the
planet would be mercury and it could
have evolved or closer or even closer
than ever curia okay
so that's kind of an imagination
stimulator a little sandbox creator for
us oh and and we have detected many such
planets and dwarf yeah
and the Doppler method has now detected
several such planets in the habitable
zone around these M Dwarfs so we've come
to understand that looking for M dwarfs
is a good way to find planets
are probably temperature similar to
earth though they're very close to these
stars and there's still some debate
about whether or not that's a healthy
thing thank you the star even though
your temperature might be okay
yeah because another thing about these M
dwarfs is they tend to be what we call
very active they they have many solar
flares they have lots of stuff flowing
out and that could do bad things to your
life yeah an attentional for life now a
majority of what we've understood about
cosmic evolution because of this has
been that it is more like it's most
likely that as a solar system evolves
that a majority of this mass gets
concentrated in these like hot Jupiter
asked planets that are orbiting right is
that oh if I were to take your words
very strictly but really no so let's
talk about the discoveries that are
coming out of the Kepler the main Kepler
prime mission
the the hot Jupiters were the first ones
found but that's because they were easy
to find there because they're big
planets close to their star and star
they've got short orbits they're just
easy to find mm-hmm relatively speaking
but they're easier than any other kind
of plant fine so they were the ones that
were found first and they tend to be in
our imaginations cuz they were found
first and you know it's a very romantic
to talk about how to produces and that's
like that's a bias towards that's
exactly yeah exactly the right word it's
a bias what Kepler has shown is that
actually how to Pater's are in the
minority there's a lot more small stars
yeah
[Music]
there there tend to be a lot of stars so
sorry a lot more small planets I
misspoke there's a lot more small
planets smaller than than Jupiter and in
fact the biggest surprise of Kepler with
in terms of things that were completely
unexpected one of the biggest surprises
is that the majority of planets that
Kepler observed are in size are between
Earth and Neptune yeah now that's a
pretty big difference in size you have
tune is about four times the size of
four times the diameter of the earth and
and there's really no planets in our
solar system in that size range but if
Kepler has shown that the majority of
planets around other stars are in that
size range between Earth and Neptune so
that was a big surprise it said that's
where the majority is concentrate that's
between Earth and Neptune sighs well
that's right okay and then in terms of
orbits it seems to be pretty much all
the orbits are filled sort of equally
likely between those as well so the
majority of planets are going to be
within Earth to Neptune oh I didn't mean
sorry I just meant all orbits seemed to
be pretty well represented Oh orbits
period from Oh from Mercury to from
tending orbits to from yeah ten-day
orbits on okay so so there's no kind of
the distribution of something that's
higher I wouldn't say there's no
distribution but we don't know really
well no we do we do no I wouldn't say
there's no distribution but but down
average all the orbits seem to be
presumed pretty pretty equally likely
okay you know from a very grossly
there's a little bit structure we're
still studying the data to pin that down
but but the big surprise was that
there's a there's a lot of these Neptune
sized planets
sorry sub neptune 7f two of
superantispyare solar system yeah so
it's like kind of able to be habitable
but also not oh that depends on where it
is so in terms of habitability that's a
big question and which is reviving a lot
of thoughts about that but but our
general prejudice is that when we talk
about habitable planet what we mean is
something that's the right temperature
and is rocky
generally speaking now that's not to say
that nothing else is habitable it's just
that those are the planets
we have an example of an inhabited one
it's called the earth that so so to the
extent that we're just looking at us
looking for a circumstance that's
similar to earth
we looking for a temperature that's
similar to earth where you can have
liquid water and we're looking for
something that's likely to have a rocky
surface so one of the very important
discoveries come out of Kepler and the
follow-up observations is that by by
looking at kepler planets detecting
kepler planets which remember Kepler
used as a transit method which tells us
the size of the planet but not its mass
and then you have the Doppler method
that tells you its mass there's a
several hundred planets for which we've
now done both measurements both the
transit and the Doppler method on the
same planet so we can tell their mass
and their size yes and give a shout-out
to Loren Weiss
who is it Tantra now
I can't remember the name of the
University in Toronto sorry Lauren
who has done the analysis of the work
and and some earlier work that was done
with by the Berkeley group that has
shown that it's that by comparing the
mass and the size of the planet
you can make a pretty good guess as to
whether it's rocky or if it's like more
gaseous
Neptune is yes change yes and it looks
like it looks like there's a break at
about one and a half one point six times
the diameter of the earth it looks like
there's a break we're below one point
six times the diameter of the earth
it's rocky above sorry one point six
Earth masses not damaged yeah one point
six Earth masses
it's rocky above it's probably gaseous
we're without that boundary is kind of
mixed so in terms of habitability we
still have these super Earths which you
know can be twice the size of the earth
less than one point six earth masses we
have these super Earths but they
and so they could be Rocky they could be
habitable if they're in the right place
for the right temperature relative to
their star but then when you get to the
larger when you get to the larger
planets which are still subbed up tuned
there you've got a lot more gases you
may not have a rocky surface if it's in
the habitable zone it may be covered by
a very very very deep oceans so there
may be water planets we don't really
know for sure but but that's where the
evidence is pointing so so habitability
is a tricky thing I mean after all our
oceans are habitable inhabited but we
don't know if
if the rocky surface was required for
information of life yeah because that we
could potentially have life on Europa
and Enceladus and Titan right and those
are way out in the gaseous planets but
they've turned out to be rocky with some
yeah those are moons orbiting the gas
secrets right so they they have surfaces
we're pretty sure Europa has a very deep
ocean underneath ice so dust has these
like geysers yeah Titan has the methane
lakes and ocean so this is so maybe we
maybe we touch on the
kind of the the ones that are that we
know to be that we've studied now to be
earth-like maybe we kind of talked about
those well we're very careful to avoid
the phrase earth-like remember we don't
see the planet so having to a bull is
better well we will say earth size and
is our favorite criticized in the
habitable zone that's good that's our
favorite phrase yeah
and that could be you know very close to
a small M star or it could be you know
in an earth-sized orbit around a
sun-like star and we've had like a
couple hundred of these
will this is so we were going to talk
about the problem of false positives
yeah why not let's so the thing is these
small planets these small planets are
very hard to find they have very funny
with the transit method they have very
tiny dips the problem is that those dips
can be caused by other things and so you
do have to be careful so we have to
answer your question we have a few tens
of rocky planets in habitable zones that
we're pretty comfortable with that are
probably really real planets but you'll
note I'm saying pretty comfortable with
that are probably real yes when I pick
any individual one it's very difficult
to say for sure that that one is
earth-sized planet in the habitable zone
but I think we could say with some
confidence that a large fraction of
these 50 or so our earth sized planets
and their habitable zones but the
problem of distinguishing these very
tiny signals from things that are faking
it there's a very difficult problem that
we're still struggling with yeah and the
things that are faking it would maybe be
something like when you're observing the
transit the planet transiting the star
that maybe it only only recorded it
transiting three times or maybe two or
there was some sort of other discrepancy
in the data right that is causing you
guys to not have a full yes moment well
it's probably that but there are also
things in the sky that can look a lot
like transits so there are asteroid well
no there are there are stars in fact
most stars and most stars are in what we
call multiple star systems where we wait
most we most stars we are in multiple I
think I
it's actually well that the binary stars
two star systems and multiple star
systems more than two star systems are
one third that's one third I think I
think well okay when you look up in the
sky pick a star yeah you're about
equally likely to pick a star that's
really just a single star or like or a
star that's when I said multiple I mean
double I know yeah so so I thought that
number was only one-third one-third of
stars are either two or more star system
well half the stars so I'm thinking of
the visible stars system also when you
start to think about the M stars what
you're saying is probably more likely
true I'm talking about when I just look
up in the visible sky
half the stars are going to be two or
more part of star system yeah so anyway
you've got these stars that are orbiting
each other in these multiple star
systems just think about two stars for
the moment yeah there were two each
other now and occasionally they'll line
up and they'll get in front of each
other now when that usually when that
happens that's really easy to tell that
that's what's happening because you've
got two stars and then they get in front
of each other and now it looks like one
star and that's a big change in
brightness much bigger than any Janet
could ever account for it so that's
great
we'll never mistake that for a planet
but sometimes they don't line up exactly
but they'll line up just a little bit
and you'll get one just kind of cut in
the corner just kind of cutting across
we called that a grazing transit it's
like is grazing transit yeah we're sorry
grazing - klipse crazy yeah grazing -
klipse
and and their the Dipple can be very
small and of course by just having
Gray's it's just a tiny little bit I can
make that dip the size of a planet so we
come up with all these different
techniques to tell the difference
between that and an actual planet we're
actually pretty good at that but another
very pernicious situation is where I
have a real fully eclipsing binary that
if it were by itself would be easy to
tell that it was two stars and not a
planet
but then I've got another planet maybe
the one I'm actually think I'm looking
at you know in the foreground that's a
big bright thing and way in the distance
is this binary star but I don't even
know about because it's behind the other
star what happens is the delight from
the star I'm looking at that stays
steady no a planet nothing went in front
of it but it gets added together with
the light from this binary and and
because the the foreground star is
nearer and brighter and the binary is
far away and dim it's just that even
though the dip from the binary by itself
looks really big when you add them
together it becomes a tiny dip on the
combination and so that's a particularly
pernicious situation that can imitate a
planet yeah
and so we've gotten sort of good in
identifying those but as I'd like to be
so those are the things in the sky that
can give you problems and then there is
the telescope itself there's always
noise from the telescope and everyone
smile you get lucky or unlucky depending
on your perspective and the noise adds
up to look just like a dip and then
you'll get another one where the noise
adds up to look like a dip over here and
you go oh I've got two dips let's look
for third one and very rarely you'll get
a third the noise adding up just right
to look like a dip over there and so
that certainly happens that some of
these triple events turn out to be
just noise and so you got to be very
careful about this and this is why we're
very careful when we say statistically
speaking we know that for example the
three noise thing adding up that has to
be very rare that can't happen very
often so statistically speaking if I've
got fifty you know a parent earth-sized
planets with tiny little dips most of
those can't be this noise adding up
because that's just - nobody's that
lucky but but maybe one or two of the
minutes and I can't tell which ones this
is so important because within science
we need to make sure that our evidence
is as accurate as possible and that
we're releasing that to the world after
we've checked it twice three times like
you said if it's not transiting more
than three times we can't count it right
so when I add to what you just said it's
not just make the evidence as accurate
as possible like our situation is we
made it as accurate as possible and
still not as accurate as we want and so
you have to be very forthcoming and very
straightforward and honest about saying
you know here's the limits of what we
can say about
but here's here's the evidence but
here's his limitations yeah so what was
the total amount of exoplanets have been
discovered by Kepler you think I know
this number just like 5,000 well first
of all it depends what we call
discovered so we have two classes well
they actually have three classes of
planets we have what are called planet
candidates those are more or less by
definition those are things where we've
we've applied all these checks I just
talked about to see if it can be faked
and it's passed all the checks but we
know that there's still things that can
be faked that we might have missed and
so a planet candidate is something that
were 90% confident in so if I have a
hundred of them 100 planet candidates
then ten of them probably aren't really
planets but I don't know which ones okay
so those are called planet candidates of
those I do you think I'd remember these
numbers but you know they've gotten so
big I don't but anyway we've got some
some
in the neighborhood of 5,000 planet
candidates yeah and then there is what
we call the statistically validated
planets where for various reasons we
haven't talked about the multiplying
systems yet but for example if we have
multiple transiting events around a star
mm-hmm it's really hard to imagine how
anything could fake that statistically
speaking and so we call those planets
statistically validated and there's
other ways to statistically validate
planets to to take that 10 percent
confidence and turn it into one percent
confidence and we call those
statistically validated and there is a
good 20 good
22000 in some of those don't remember
the name do you do you think that if if
we had another civilization let's say
was observing our star system and that
they were using a transit method to
observe the planets orbiting do you
think earth the difference between earth
transiting and Mars transiting between
their telescope and our star do you
think that would be very easily
detectable that's only earth is what
like 8,000 miles in diameter and Mars is
like 4,000 miles in diameter so is that
like we have planet candidates at arm
our size but you have to remember those
are only planet candidates we're not
that's 90% sure of those so we if we can
do it they can do it now one interesting
thing about our solar systems is a great
segue into the multiple my suing when
interesting thing about our solar system
is that the planets aren't all lined up
the you know the earth is orbiting this
way then Mars is orbiting at a slight
angle and Nina's deserved a slightly
different angle so one interesting thing
about our solar system is if some alien
were pointing their alien Kepler the Sun
and they happen to catch the earth they
probably wouldn't see the other planets
at all yeah because the angle the the
the other
it's would miss they would be above or
below the star after went through that's
because that spread in the ankles yeah
so one of the other really big surprises
from Kepler is the number of multiple
planet systems that we've seen where you
have one star with several planets with
different orbits transiting across it
we've gotten as many as eight now on a
single star system and what that means
is those around us know eight the eight
is just recently announced
yeah it's been the original ones Chapas
is fun too yeah it is but but but the
surprise is that that means that these
planets are orbiting in a much flatter
collection of orbit around around their
Sun so so this was one of the fun things
you know the whole point of taking these
observations is to help us understand
how where planets come from a common
planets are and stuff and so before
Kepler there was
you know there were many theories of how
the planets formed and all those
theories were designed to make a planet
system that looks like our solar system
but now the Kepler has found all these
multiple planet systems where they're if
they're flat they're also densely packed
many of them are densely packed where
there are as many plants as you could
possibly have and you try to put another
one in there its gravity would throw
everything off that's not like our solar
system in our solar system there's lots
of room for more planets that aren't
there yeah whereas in these in these
systems these these planets are very
densely packed you could plan it and hop
really easily between the planets
because they're good yeah because
they're so close and then also it's
because the star is a little bit dimmer
once again relatively speaking but yes
these are much more densely packed the
planet systems are already much that
these plants are already much closer
together like eight planets between our
star and Mars
it's something like that so some of them
are even more densely packed than that
yeah and the stars dimmer so they're
gonna be potentially multiple habitable
I always found the the potential
habitable planet that had that was Title
II law and had that ring potential
habitability this is one side one side
is so cold one side so hot but then
there's this ring of habitable I just
thought that was so fasting when I first
saw that you just expand in my mind all
these new possibilities
I'm just so the problem I should say the
problem I mean what you're describing
where so she's describing a situation
where the planet is so close to the star
that is tightly locked so one face of
the planet always faces the star just
like in our Moon are the moon orbiting
the Earth is tightly locked in one face
to the moon always faces the earth and
so that means that it's always starla
it's always day's light and one part of
the star and it's always night and the
other part of the star and this has to
be pretty close to the star and so it's
hi and so on the light side it's really
really hot but you know there's that
edge where it transitions from day to
night where it might be cool enough the
light may life may be so sure there
certainly has to be such an edge the
thing is when you think about what the
atmosphere is such a planet would do
yeah it's complicated and so I'm not
sure anybody I'm not sure there's a
consensus about what would happen but
the kinds of things that can happen is
that the atmosphere will freeze out in
the night so yeah and so no atmosphere
no life another thing that can happen is
it doesn't freeze out in the night side
because more sophisticated simulations
have showed that the winds would
circulate the heat but you would have
very high winds on the boundary so pop
my creativity with truth it's with
reason and truth hopefully hopefully
there is one planet so let's so let's
this is this is cool because you know
thinking about alien telescopes looking
at our star I like to think about the
the newest sort of way that we want to
analyze the composition of these
atmospheres maybe we talk yeah let's
talk about it let's talk about that you
can talk about tests and talk about
James Webb but also just the idea of
choreography this yeah being able to
throw up a sunshade and like block not
most of the Starlight and be able to
break up the light of what is hitting a
planet through a prism and be able to
analyze which exact elements are present
on that planet is so interesting yes
let's do this as talking about the
future you know sorry starting now
so one this is a particularly exciting
moment because within well sometime in
March we hope to see the launch of the
next NASA telescope to look for planets
around other stars that's called the
tests mission for a transiting exoplanet
survey satellite I was very fortunate by
the way to see the test satellite three
weeks ago
where is that being so it's being
assembled in Virginia by orbital ATK
cool
and I just was in the right place I was
standing next to the right person at the
right time to go along amazing so I saw
it sitting there it's very cute yeah
it's a lot smaller than Kepler very cute
yeah so that's going to be launched next
in the next three months or so and
[Music]
what's special about that is it's got a
very different approach than Kepler
Kepler so first of all when Kepler
launched we only had maybe a hundred
planets most of which were hot Jupiters
that we knew about around other stars
and we didn't know what planets were
common or not yeah and so Kepler
launched did this thing's just looking
at a bunch of stars for a long time and
found a bunch of planets and which
answered the question said yes planets
are common so now the next step is it
makes sense to now look at all the
nearby stars two bright nearby stars and
look for planets around those so you had
to know that planets were coming first
before you did that because if they're
not coming you just wasting your time
right so the test mission is designed
specifically to look for planets around
nearby stars and it's almost certainly
going to be successful and it uses the
transit method also
and it's so it's going to look sin Chi
over very nearly the whole sky not quite
the whole sky but that look at almost
every star in the sky
in nearby specific we're looking here
but it's it's got a brightness limit so
it'll look at everything that's at a
reasonable brightness
which means which translates into mostly
new buy stores yeah
and then also this is a contra does the
light bucket does the mirrors is the
mirrors
are they mostly throughout the entirety
of the satellite or is it only one
concentration how is it looking
everywhere so it's got so what it does
is actually has four cameras and their
cameras not even mirrors I mean you know
they're just cameras with nice lenses
vibrating is that is that the new future
we're not using mirrors anymore well no
no no this was just this is just how
since this is going for bright stars you
didn't need a big telescope
so so this was a way to get oh yeah so
so and you have and you have these these
big lenses so that each each camera is
looking at a significantly larger chunk
of the sky than Kepler did Kepler does
and so there are four cameras and
they're arranged so that you can get a
strip of sky that covers almost 90
degrees yeah that's amazing yeah so the
four cameras are will be observing strip
of sky all at once and so if I remember
my numbers right I'm not on the test
mission so I might get something that's
wrong if I remembered my numbers right
it's going to look
it's it's going to look at one strip of
the sky for 27 days and then turn look
at the next strip of the sky for 27 days
then turn and so on and that way it'll
cover the entire sky and so first does
the NARC first actually does itself and
awesome and then it doesn't it's gonna
do everywhere it's yeah look everywhere
almost it's gonna it's going to miss the
strip around the middle because that's
right design compromise so so that's
going to find a lot of planets around
bright nearby stars and that's important
for the next step which is even though
it's transiting and you only see the
shadow of the planet if the star is
bright enough and
and the the planet is big enough you can
actually tell you can actually detect
the absorption of the Starlight from the
planet's atmosphere and and we've
already had a small number of successes
you know using the Spitzer Space
Telescope observing transiting giant
planets and observing signs of the
they're able to actually measure the
composition from how it absorbs the
sunlight
so we're basically comparing the color
of the star before the planet gets in
front of it to the color of the star
when the planets in front of it yeah I
mean that way we can get a measurement
of the
chemical composition of the of the
planet's atmosphere
now that really only works for large
planets around bright stars but that's
going to that's one of the main goals of
test is to be able to identify planets
where you can do that that's going to be
a major next step and the James Webb
Space Telescope is going to be one of
the main instruments for actually
measuring the change in color of the
star and so you can think of it as that
test will be identifying the planets
that are good for the James Webb Space
Telescope to observe the so that's
that's using the that's still using the
transit method you know the transit
method the wobble method a couple other
less less common methods the mirror on
James Webb is yeah it's checking out at
24 feet or something versus eight feet
for Hubble something it's really it's
James Webb's gonna be launched with the
mirror folded up yeah
so but the future the farther future
though is the choreography that you were
talking about which is where you find a
way to block the light from the star and
not block the light from the planet and
then you can actually see the planet so
all these methods up to now you're not
actually seeing the planet you're seeing
the planets shadow or you're seeing the
planets gravity but but what we're
looking for is to build telescopes where
you're blocking the light from the star
which is a lot harder than it sounds
could be life taking this and putting it
up there well if it were that simple it
wouldn't be that hard so if it were if
it were enough to just put a little dot
where the star is we could do that the
problem is that when when you it would
be a very small dot because the star is
very far away and so the star is really
really tiny it's almost essentially a
point the problem is that when you have
dots that small the light doesn't behave
the way you expect you get diffraction
effects where the light bleeds are on
the edge of the dot correct and if you
make the dot big enough to not have that
happen now you're blocking my planet so
what you have to do is get clever and
and what you do is you if you if you
insist on using a dot what you do is you
kind of see rate the edge of the dot you
give
edge of a data texture which if it's
designed just right will actually cause
that diffraction to cancel out what
would the texture be on the outside of
that there's well there's different
there's different approaches sometimes
it's a sort of a sometimes it's sort of
a serration like I said a knife
sometimes it's a very complicated shape
where the light actually comes through
the complicated shape
now there's two ways to block the light
one is to have a telescope where the
light gets focused inside the telescope
and then you put a little dot where the
focus is and that's called a that's
called a coronagraph I'm actually
involved in this star shade as the other
I'll get to that
so I'm actually involved in some of the
design for next-generation coronagraphs
it's a long time these days that's very
exciting and then but that's still
really hard to do is give me the light
in the telescope and blocking the light
in this awesome that's really hard to do
yeah because you're working with very
very tiny dot so they have to be just
right it's really amazing yeah so some
folks came up with this other absolutely
crazy sounding idea where what they do
is instead of a dot inside the telescope
you have your telescope over here and
then you have a shade that's way over
there and you line them up so the shade
blocks light of the star but
but to but but to have the shade block
just a light of the Sara nothing lay of
the planet these things have to be
hundreds of thousands of kilometers
apart really far apart which means
you've got to have a lined up really
perfectly and keep them lined up and
then say you want to look over there
you've got to find a way to both of them
it's crazy so it's crazy sounding but it
has tremendous if you can do it it's got
tremendous advantages and so both ways
in the composition of a planet well so
the point of both of these methods is to
see the planet take pictures of the
planet in color yeah and if you can
detect the colours of the planet then
you can measure it out here yeah and
then you could look for the kinds of
chemicals like for example oxygen is
very suggestive of life it's not
completely definitive but it's very
suggestive that there's active life if
you can see oxygen in the atmosphere
but but the question is is the
coronagraph the best way to do it or is
a starshade the best way to do these
days NASA is pushing hard and both of
them yeah yeah to figure it out yeah so
let's do a couple rapid-fire thoughts
about this so the Drake Equation famous
maybe we say one out of every five
planets or stars has a planet in the
habitable zone let's say and let's say
then let's approximate right not a bad
guess exactly yeah the data is
consistent with that yeah what not so my
question then what do you think do you
think that we're alone in the cosmos
yeah boy here I have to say I don't
speak I'm not going to speak for NASA
I'm not speaking for this so get in
trouble
because this is just a personal opinion
now which is actually fairly uninformed
I'm an observational astronomer there
are people who think about this question
of of life and and life and intelligence
and other planets to do that for a
living and I'm not one of those people
so my my opinion is not terribly
informative but here's the things I
think about when you ask the question
there's this thing called the famous
Fermi paradox yeah by Enrico Fermi which
which can be summed up as saying where
are they yeah so you know the earth is
about four billion years old the
universe is about 13.7 billion years old
there are stars that are much older than
the Sun which almost certainly have
planets
and
if life were common they you know then
some of those planets should have life
if life were common we don't know if
life is coming here and then what would
happen if some of them developed
technological civilizations like we had
well they would have a million years
start on us
or more and you would think that our
technology our technological
capabilities extrapolated a million
years into the future you think we've
been doing things that you can detect
from the other side of the galaxy
correct yeah but when we look and we're
really good at looking in the sky and
looking at what stars and stuff are
doing and we don't see anything that
doesn't just fit the natural
understanding
of what we see we don't see anything
that hints at some technology doing
stuff and you know given that some of
these if these civilizations existed
some of them should have had a million
years start on us why don't we see it
where are they I mean I could understand
why they're not here because travel
between stars is really really really
really hard and I could imagine that
that's and there's a million years in
advance well it's still really hard so I
I'm willing to concede that maybe they
won't be here I mean Rico Fermi was
saying why aren't they here so I'm
willing to concede they were there maybe
wouldn't be here because interstellar
travel is just too hard that's possible
but it's not so easy to concede that
they wouldn't be doing stuff that we
could detect correct and we don't detect
anything like it so where are they so I
don't know so here's another thought
that comes to mind is one thing that
really is good I mean we only have one
example of life in the universe that we
know about and that's here on earth yes
and one thing that's striking about that
is that there's fossil evidence for life
you know pretty close to when the earth
was cool enough for the first time to be
habitable I mean the earth was formed in
some very violent events and you know
something hit the earth and form the
earth-moon system it was really violent
really a bad place to be if there was
life it would have gotten completely
wiped out and it took a while for the
earth to cool down after those events
and even though this is it's a difficult
you know difficult to get the numbers
exactly right to know exactly what
happened
the fossil evidence for life on Earth
goes back to not that far after when the
earth was you know hospitable to life
which says that life happened kind of as
soon as it could is what that suggests
now that's only one data point maybe we
just got really lucky but if life
happened as soon as it could that sort
of suggests that you know life will
happen anywhere it could and so things
like that that are interesting that
light happened quickly animal life just
even having multicellular life took a
really long time so life at the level of
single celled things you know might be
extremely common but animal life might
be rare rare and then it took a long
time to develop ur you know conscious
conscious beings being technology thing
as opposed to conscious you know so so
animal you know multicellular life that
makes animals might be rare and then
technology might be even rarer yeah on
the other hand there's a lot of stars do
I have an opinion I'm just gonna say no
I don't have an opinion but I wonder
about these things just talking about do
you like the zoo hypothesis the idea
that we're trapped in a little cage and
that's cool
civilizations are waiting until we
unlock teleportation before they talk to
us III know I'm yeah I know you were an
advanced civilization you were observing
them the inferior civilizations you
would you
want them to know about you right you
like I might not but I'll wager
quite a lot that some other civilization
will come along in that care and so much
say hi yeah sure sure so in other words
the zoo hypothesis assumes that
everybody's doing the same thing and so
it doesn't maybe there's only one
supreme beam in the galaxy who knows
whatever whatever
yeah if there was only one Supreme Being
in the galaxy
who was imposing their will on everyone
else I would think we could see it I
know so so it's
there we're very low on the Kardashev
scale the the weird wheat or wheat we
haven't even harvested the full power of
our that's right
let alone the power of the star that is
next to us which is type two
civilizations so we're like point seven
civilization let's say so the type three
civilizations can Arvest all the powers
of the stars in their whole galaxy and
so so right now we're in terms of like
maximizing human potential how do we
work together figure this out on earth
colonizers to our other planets keep
going what do you think how do we I wish
I had anything sensible to say about
that but I don't what about what am I
really like a baby step like a
short-term baby step well I'm actually
fairly pleased with what we're doing now
you know I'm very happy to say that that
the search for other planets and stuff
is very well supported throughout all
cultures as far as I can tell everybody
gets excited about it that's a good
point the US government is very
supportive of it
I won't speak for other governments yeah
so that is a baby stuff it's just just
discovering that these planets are out
there is yeah I think just the right
baby step for right now
what's the next baby step I you know I
live long enough to know that my
thoughts usually are wrong about these
things
tonight let me ask you this we're about
to go into ten years in about the next
10 years or so we're gonna see some
pretty strong civilizational dispute
over territory on Mars oh not well let's
let's see your perspective on this
should we colonize Mars globally or
nationally oh I
about that question so I'm not going to
happen
I don't I don't well maybe go home and
think about it and send me a message
well
the difference between doing something
globally and doing something nationally
is something we're still learning how to
do yeah and I think we'd have to learn
more about how to do that
which you know I think we're taking baby
steps in that direction so
yeah I'm excited to see how much
national work we do with space and with
all these other new technologies that
are emerging mapping the brain the
genome the nanotech versus collaboration
as a world understanding blockchain
together and implementing that
everywhere and understanding space and
going in conquering Mars as a
civilization and all these kind of
things I'm really the shining example of
that of course is the International
Space Station
that is a great shining example of where
we are learning to do something globally
example and and it's certainly been said
that for example going to Mars is
something that no single nation could
possibly afford but but I like when I
hear people say that no single nation
could possibly afford it because then
they say oh the only way to do it is
cooperatively I love I love the idea of
cooperating and I love the idea of
innovating and wanting to be the first
and hustling and stuff but I love that
if cooperating so do you think we're in
a computer simulation
oh that's even goofier straight up no
yeah that's even goofier I as we talked
about before the show I actually have
had a significant career in virtual
reality and no absolutely not you don't
think you don't think you should stay
agnostic
no no just straight up night I know
anthropomorphic projection when I see it
it's like oh we've been doing virtual
reality and so oh everything must be
free it's like the Indian trust me in 20
years there's gonna be some new fancy
technology that people are enchanted
with and they're gonna say that's what
the universe is well well well even
though you're right that a lot of it
came from the virtual reality of today's
kind of huge marketing plays and
everything
actually more of it for me comes from
harnessing the power of the star or of
nuclear fusion once one sure what's once
able to take in those massive amounts of
energy and then do things with that I
feel like simulating a world for other
people to live in becomes much easier
so that's that's how I feel about it
okay I will just say that it's not
nearly as you think correct but all over
then again humanity is in its infancy
really yeah absolutely you've done a
good job leading up here we have water
and we have food and we have electricity
and education things like that but we're
still in our infancy we're playing
around with all these technologies like
AI and robotics in engineering and we're
doing them in ways that are like little
kids with firecrackers and and where
that's going to go is impossible to
imagine that's right and and the
corollary for that for me is that since
it's impossible to imagine the thing
we're imagining right now probably isn't
it
good stuff awesome so Steve Bryson yep
thank you so much for joining us this is
great conversation we're really looking
forward to seeing what you do what NASA
does in the future I can't even believe
k2 is still forget just can you believe
that k2 still going 90 days 90 days 90
days it's amazing what the team's have
been able to put together to keep that
functioning thanks for all the
conversation about space everyone thank
you so much for tuning in my name is
Alan sockin we have you guys tuning in
we have a patreon account you guys can
become a member by donating to us we're
then give you and return some of
benefits cool benefits include exclusive
content it includes access to events
early access priority to ask our guests
questions and
[Music]
take a look join into the community if
you'd like this video please give it a
like give it a comment give it a share
with other people we would greatly
appreciate that again huge shout out to
Ron Vargas our epic director behind the
TriCaster doing great work and again
thank you guys so much for tuning in and
thanks Steve
take an awesome thank you
we're out okay not bad it was about an
hour hour 15 not bad
yeah really appreciate it yeah